spin turn spin turn spin spin turn ha ha
ha okay dead kittens dead kittens dead
kittens spin turn spin turn spin spin
turn ha
okay all right
we flying set recording sarsen was not
it's just I'm so excited it's the sequel
to the holiday special we're completely
wrecked counting the problems at the
last one why don't you just done once
you just jump to Lightspeed that's
always the answer you want you know what
let me get one no I fuck you camera is a
special good get one with a reaction
shot from him as well
okay oh you dropped your stirrup since
the shots already set up so yeah this
time just reactor that we just got okay
all right rolling on both cleanse it and
I'm sorry cinema snob it's just I'm so
excited it's the sequel to the Star Wars
Holiday Special we're completely
reckoning the problems of the last one
once you just jump to Lightspeed that's
always the answer
god this feels like causes ignoring it
I'm sorry I haven't been able to
understand what you can say through my
past 30 years since I quit drinking okay
let's go ahead we'll move this out of
the way rolling it bring it back one
more time later then why didn't you just
shoot oh good we have different passions
and stuff guys are like family to me
oh where is it that wine is like I think
I have a spot but like yeah it's like
everybody from in it so you saw it too
right the new one yeah oh yeah yes idea
we saw it on the Thursday night
screening oh I was pecked oh yeah yeah I
get I got there like two three hours
early so well I I was only planning on
being there like an hour or so early
like I usually do it something like that
but I was talking to my buddy and he was
like I'm wedding are getting there like
a couple hours or at least like
Wednesday or Thursday oh we got there
like an hour I mean it worked for us
they were it probably would have worked
yet we would have gotten Sega but they
had the whole they took over the whole
theater for Star Wars yeah they did for
awhile there was one there was one
screen that was showing sisters I would
have referred Sister Act
I'm glad the benefit of getting of that
Earl is we at least got our regular
seats so like we would have gotten seats
together but at least this way like oh
we were in our usual spot though the
rail job my wife and I we got the
railroad yeah yeah we got there we got
there about 50 minutes early somebody
took the dead center so we were just
right at dead center and I'm like this
is sweet I love the people who were
showing up five minutes beforehand and
walking in and he's clearly just like Oh
Dora scrappy crumble I did Oh No there
was a wood we went to go see sisters the
next day oh there was a it was at that
was also kind of crowded but it was like
50 year old men were in the audience and
so this around the corner comes this guy
who's in this Jedi robe and lightsaber
and just ooh
so the coat Hailey's like whoops wrong
theater uh meanwhile in the Star Wars
line meanwhile on the Star Wars line
someone's dressed like Tina Fey line
four sisters right buddy interesting if
you
and look DeRozan huh sat down that's
what he said I could be great if he just
he didn't get a ticket beforehand so he
stuck seeing sister just don't think you
should just insert the you're like
family to me at the most inopportune
moments no no that is a much the aunt a
very nice API gives you're like family
so like family no it's like kids he says
where do I drown - son you're like
family awesome oh no I got everywhere
it's like it what what is Hanako really
about Oh grab this ball I'll show you
it's like you're like family to me Craig
yeah should we just grab I look damn
good say this three step save energy
crap I would I say that head looked down
and there's an insert shot of lumpy like
not Dana Dana was posing Jesus like I
love BB and I was like he's a woman
first balls
damn straight all right he had cut of
the gut out like yeah I think what we'll
be looking yeah kind of like this know
what I love the height difference works
this time Doug you may need to be a
little taller in fact um it's more
facial hair okay yes I mean basically I
mean like the shot that you we were home
shot uh and we're just have a little low
angle
I think this had to be exact but if you
want get a little angle is fine so yeah
we're just gonna step in you say you
know we got a little yeah before Malcolm
is fouled this thing like just like two
steps okay I need you guys to step on to
critic we're home
yep it's the same old coloring book
cover that we're used to come on I want
you to be my extended family for her so
you guys get the H out you said 400 okay
the ages I'm I still think we should
call it Chu Hanukkah so ass down critics
Jewish yeah and as a family of George's
haha I do it
Shabana huh I'm gonna give you a car off
shot so you can digitally zoom it if you
want to um
we're gonna have it tight more for the
sound to the sound to pick it up better
shit's a little tighter your toes I mean
yeah what zoom is connected to them no
okay I can't do anymore so okay this is
Malcolm so it's nearly done but there's
still a few pieces missing yeah we'll
get one piece around his stomach we've
we've got his codpiece on yeah we made
it extra large you know the myth is true
okay and look at that hell with that
difficult to move not bad well in
consider these things are made out of
this armors made out of rubber oh wow oh
yeah there we go
strong trooper oh I think we need to
raise this up just a touch fill in this
that's black space yeah
ah hell are you lost on the show really
oh wait that one breaks yeah to your
facial expression looks so good Malcolm
is trying to be my storms rubyist
well you know what's interesting the
Stormtrooper guys must be relatively
small because when you see John boyega
walking away his thighs are so large
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah yeah okay well
let's let's go in and show everyone okay
you're ready for him oh my god is that a
white guy in there actually the biggest
E's doing like the Luke Skywalker thing
I can barely see in this thing move
there you go okay we're gonna go ahead
we'll do the other white shot um all
right get over yes and thanks go ahead
grab the stuff hey she stepped back and
he drank away grab the stuff they're
like
for uh Tamara did you still have the
richer okay give the ribbon I know I
never took a I never took this either oh
okay go ahead and have yeah yeah say you
just go ahead and give a hug yeah Brad
just can't leave your camera rolling
your eyes
dude okay what's happening it's after
she has all the stuff it gives you a hug
you just sort of like you don't embrace
her you just her the Thomas hall award
classes yes so those breasts oh haha
okay all right ready as soon as I say
action Terry does it with Ravi Oh what's
everybody want one of the of thus a dog
from back here yeah no I can I can do
that
okay funny on its honey on its own but
knowing the movie dinner parties where
you funnier oh okay go ahead will do one
more from the beginning go ahead put the
stuff down on this one we're gonna end
with um uh yeah slow bread okay go ahead
said that sub down for that we're headed
to walking okay okay
Brad one more step back oh sorry
back alright ready and action
good
okay grab go grab the stuff there Tamara
Oh how's this generally thing John
alright and yet this will be the slow
embrace never get both of you take half
a step this way
I'll be good okay ready and action
oh I know you can do it
lover
all right all ready and action
do one more do whatever you did there
but squeeze have really died of bread
after couples legs just and Tara bells
great with the eyes keep doing with the
igf all right ready mm-hmm
and action I know you can do it
good good uh okay this is so difficult
just like oh god I stuck like this okay
punch it's a pretty good let's get I'm
gonna get Jim in the camo outfit then ah
Jim yeah let's see you film now when
your own stormtrooper outfit huh how
does it not hit anything when they're
shooting could I look no no when I
experiment on like when we were doing
the sibling rivalry that's the first
thing I realize oh no wonder they can't
hit Jax you can't see a fucking thing
with this thing uh yeah you have no
peripheral vision right in the arms
they're like I cannot live in this farm
like though that was that was the thing
about the movie that frightened the fuck
out of me I'm like holy shit storm
troopers can shoot straight now
yelling actually scared of these as
actually kidding thank you like a little
like a second
we having sex with pizza never saw it on
Twitter say you've never see Balta pussy
I was talking about see that was the
problem now they don't have the clones
anymore is it was like originally when
it was the clones it was like
multiplicity every time you make a copy
they keep getting dumber
so it's a bunch of crazy Michael
Keaton's under djz we finally get
Michael Keaton and Star Wars and this is
what he's playing I get it now are you
looking at that's not what I ordered
yeah you look going to school yeah hey
Liz all this time before some teaming up
coming tonight
Wow are you are you happy you're
beautiful you can either miss me go
ahead and gain up you are kinder hey
this may be the first time in my time
I've have actually ever worn lipstick so
what was putting it up though I mean
dark Rob so it sucks
yeah yeah and why I'm sure this may be
the second ahead Brad that's right you
violated me he left maniacally okay for
now this drug hangover it's still with
me now this is showing how to spin a
dreidel so you can probably oh yeah
that's a it's been toads been turning
spin - Wow spin turn spin turns me Wow
and yeah you're at a magani just a
pleasure
holiday drink drink Rimmel I made your
mother pray
I could do that for you okay well do uh
spin turn spin turn spin spin turn
flower who do you think what do you
think yeah that I smoked this morning is
finally starting to kick it kicking why
um is that okay actually spin chance pin
chance Peter
ah as we speak I mean widely learning
how to use a dreidel bingo for a
Saturday special what is it and action
spin down spin down spin spin tongue ah
good you're watching it a little bit
just Keith on the metal spin ah I'm
gonna get the third orbital spin turn
spin turn spin spin turn oh yeah you're
actually a little bit at the end just
keeping another spin turn spin down spin
spin turn Wow
it matters Eddy it does okay I've heard
this one a million times those everybody
else alright quite a set yes and
actually spin turn spin turn spin spin
turn oh okay dead kittens dead kittens
dead kittens I understand spin turn spin
turn spin spin turn ah you
the best a variety television is really
eating this up you should see my
erection
oh whoa everywhere not my special yeah
oh we ready to get back to a fuckin
nightmare and actually spin turn spin
turn spin spin - oh that forget oh yeah
that's good hey Freddy and spin down
spin turn spin spin turn good don't spot
on you know you ever think about it just
by train oh okay there's musicality to
acting deliveries
yeah okay grant is that control yeah
dragon training try to move I made you
want to trade and trade route rentals
I made you want to fall what is
happening
Hitler's miss rate your honor
alright next cup of the guild
adrenaline waah yeah you're just so you
two are gonna run I say stop here and
then like maybe even run this way so
sort of like the Falcon is here and then
you're like you know how do we get
inside like maybe that way okay
and hey ready and hey good I love it
fuck all ready and action
okay oh what its gonna be
Oh God so what its gonna be is that you
you three you're gonna start off like
maybe three steps back this way and
you're gonna walk up in the frame again
amazing Bea Arthur is right there and
when I say turn you're gonna turn around
bro you're gonna turn around and say
hello I'm Bea Arthur welcome to my
watering hole Malcolm you say please
tell me no more about your watering hole
yes and dandy say I wouldn't talk
Eraserhead and you Malcolm you try to
like that like you know you son of a and
Malcolm even Brandi given Bambi so
that's very easy here's you yeah after
he said Oh settle down settle down
um you just said you're not even a real
fighter you think we should all run yeah
now can you say so what do I do and uh
Tara you grab him you safe thing don't
ever think that only cowering fool would
right and then you look at be who's
right there
and her doom and you're gonna yeah
you're gonna have some like you're gonna
sauce it I'm going to catch it and then
I'm gonna go over here and I'm going to
toss it to you Tamra and you catch it
and as soon as you can't you get these
flashback that's what happens in the
movie it's like hey that's why I just
wanna hope her performance was better
than that
you grab it and just head but I mean
grabbin just more like a very subtle
gradually because a cursory yeah like
that yeah so the backgrounds are gonna
be like all these things and then you
just hand it to Brandi just say got a
run and you run the other direction
no no she says gotta run oh sorry yeah
yes your type of never run never run
good yeah runs midi-chlorians ha ha ha
what I wasn't there for that movie so
you're okay what going go ahead look at
uh have a right time you're gonna be out
over here not actually do what you do
you can glove for us let's do that we
can do that before we shoot them okay
all right so damn what it's going to be
is I think it's the is that tear friend
owns a good boyfriend yeah I see that up
tier it's that a dear friend in yeah ah
yeah so long ahead Robin gonna have you
back use Robin gonna be back here and
he's just gonna start
it's not the end friend don't say
goodbye friend and then you're gonna run
by and then give you stopping with your
left hand you go it's that a dear friend
and having just you know get away from
it and you go in dead you go in your eye
and then why people so what's like you
when when eyes that the end friend don't
sit goodbye forever eases don't say
goodbye friend okay and I'm doing Mike
yeah IV you're shaking the hands and
everything I think that's the big thing
is that you should two hands like
all right okay ready and action
is that the end friend yeah unless it's
not the end friend oh not goodbye my
friend all right hey what I rent it
give me the Lincoln it's not the end
friend don't say goodbye friend all
right it's not the end friend don't say
goodbye friend
is that a dear friend in your legs I
know tricks on the head yes actually it
was yeah guerilla title or ah that
sounds good yeah the big thing the Xingu
with everything of the big issues issue
went bloop it's got it what am i doing
is poor the cameras I do it you do it
you can just search there is not the end
friend don't say goodbye
God the big thing is shaking the hands I
remember I think ups dancing it Oh God
extra creepy woken up and worthless he's
right look I'm on a fucking train to st.
Louis all right right yep and action
it's not the end friend don't say
goodbye friend is that a tear friend in
your
a good I'll play a little bit I'll open
more to the camera I would say I played
more to the camera hey is that different
in your eye it's not oh it's fine
how do I mean and I say like as soon as
you grab and start saying the line even
the still moving all right that a cheer
friend
all right after friend do I take off
yeah okay yeah so definitely play more
there like a sweetheart
it's nothing yeah sky but be my favorite
new care the Blue Door Alessia and
action it's not the end friend don't say
goodbye friend
is that a tear friend in your eye
marking a lesson in your eyes oh yeah I
got like that and just more of an eye in
your eye alright that's good everybody
knows it's not the end Fred not the end
friend it more nigga Wayne yeah oh yeah
he right okay ready
yep and action it's not the end friend
it's not goodbye friend
it is that a tear friend in your
the mask you stopping up side he's tiny
hang in there
okay okay
pray that mm-hmm and action
it's not the end friend it's not goodbye
friend
yes it is that a tear friend in your eye
good
ah one more and just man what you gonna
do is that it yet just go right into it
not the end friend is that a tear friend
yours why mine is ready to get their
young'uns I mean as soon as you put the
hand on that's what you say got it right
got it yeah okay well it would be good
all right and then we're yeah we're
gonna do the stab here just just act
like you know you're stabbing them like
that yeah and then just I love you I
know
and then just ask you sir great call
okay ready yeah so as soon as I say
action s and I yeah yeah you'll have to
go too far oh just playing it yeah ready
and action
guys just just I just like glanced over
here like just I love yours like he's
call me like right as I turned I'm like
oh it's got intense
hey Brad ahead all right we'll do one
more at this dad Hey right and action
I love you
just go ahead cut that while I am
beautiful do the right yeah no just move
it like a shirt isn't it yes the force
yeah oh yeah I have to chew me yeah I
found my chameleon Han so that was great
out in vain that was something that
looks like like even though the hair Oh
technically white I think people just
remember the color blue or there's like
that blue background
coming and then oh wow yeah yeah Oh Oh
OOP the emperor boots there yeah well
but what's your fashion - nothing hot
Vader's oh how oh hey I'll later
hi oh hi baby I thought you were a wig
right yes I did sir
yes I do oh my let me not probably go
over this I don't know her right knee
type of thickness really ya know so we
pretty much just connected to like that
pointless scene where the singer sings
like that weird Wookiee porn whatever
that was and it's like well this ties in
perfectly so we put on while the seniors
playing and you pop up you just go back
Oh giant octopuses that come out of
nowhere nothing to tie into the story
but at least is shorter than the opening
of Return of the Jedi
mmm yes you gotta get in there I gotta
get into it yeah obviously I've been
sucking on my lip the entire time so
maybe fix that before yes
it was a weird moment I think about it
more it's probably trying to situate the
Han Solo still uh not very good at
paying back as dislike you always have
been
yeah yeah I mean it's just a show at his
old tricks but it's like it I need a
whole back the phone be transferring
those beasts to somebody I forgot the
name a person you got a seven like a
line of dialogue or like a minute scene
it doesn't be like this big chase or
whatever but that's I thought was kind
of funny when the door thing happened
you were little
yeah I liked him going back and forth I
mean serve art you know arguing with him
and stuff but it's like Abby
it wasn't he didn't it was so cat cool
that's cool seeing him today I was so
worried so I think it's pretty similar
like the singing thing that was
happening in was it a retailer Jenna
yeah
what at the bar uh oh yeah well that's
the redone again that still could've
been taken out yeah I know I wish I was
taking a holiday fix we're back in the
day yeah those are the improved effects
back in the day yeah yeah Scott that's
gotta be weird like growing up with like
the two different because the newer
version came out like when we were
growing up like a big sweet oh wow he
smokes new effects and stuff
I knew that cuz I remember it was a
scene with Jabba the Hutt was there all
of a sudden we never showed him yeah it
wasn't like you
we don't get any of those revisions well
I'm gonna watch the puppy version it was
kind of yeah yeah no I didn't put more
real yeah yeah practical effects chine
octopuses that come out of nowhere
none of it dying into the story but
still shorter than the opening return
feels really good
yeah you said uh but still sure the
return is really okay yeah no that was
good though that was good
it is it possible to do it a bit louder
yeah Oh God feel I know you did no I got
it I'm used to dancing around these legs
yeah that's probably why the Lighting's
just oh alright whatever it he says
still shorter than the open
angry wanting their money back
giant octopuses okay yeah yeah angry men
wanting their money back
giant octopuses that come out of nowhere
none of it tiny to the story
but still shorter than the opening a
return of the Jedi
all right look I'm gonna try one more
just for the heck of it go really over
the top with like the eyes and like
Marilyn Monroe
yeah pretty much like that very tinker's
Oh what oh yeah I'm excited
yeah you wanna get the eyes all big bug
eyes up that's my own Oh y'all get shot
in the face in the foot all right this
is my moment everyone at home just like
oh yeah
okay ready all right what are we ready
no you know Angry Men wanting their
money back giant octopuses they come Oh
none of it's tying in to the story
oh yeah
what's still shorter than the opening
just for safety one just like that no
this will be much I'm actually glad that
that's right there yeah exactly
hmm and we men wanting their money back
that's right giant octopuses that come
no time to the story
but still shorter than the opening
religion my guess is in you'll be the
over the top long live kylo Ren exactly
how I should know she's wearing boots
should I have the Empire boots yeah Oh
ring is he really really fast that is
yeah it is it's like a train people not
somebody make a gif out of it
yeah I'm white I can't do it oh yeah
let's go he just needs amazing can't
tell the difference oh yeah use your
camera - yeah right behind the seasons
so this is from ah so okay Victoria want
us to film this so that this is the cool
drawing that she done just gonna do both
camera say yes
so yeah Jan she and uh you just sent a
whole bunch of gifts to us and I didn't
know they were to all of us and they was
supposed to be open to a certain way
because what like this this was on the
top I do want rip it so I opened it the
other way and then like as I already
started oh but really handled that
package mech hair and I started to open
one and I saw the letter later as in
filming when you open and blah blah I'm
like oh shit so uh so you know one of
them's already had never made it out of
preschool read the instructions no no
they're on the way I opened it there on
the bottom but the way she had it was on
top I do everything
Martin Davalos for you uh melk I'm
assuming them out Oh milk yeah yeah yeah
got milk
yeah so abroad is not here today would
not leave it there like his mother
that's what I defer on say I'm not sure
she wanted Italy open the car I know yes
so oh maybe the greater bonds yes I got
ahead open that I yeah we didn't get
stickers on ours ours don't have the
anthrax that still yeah it's so yeah
good guards up it is all that so knife
isn't oh that's a pretty card look at
that opening mine on the binds Inc the
artist is light Oh
have a great Christmas and hope you
don't get driven up the wall too much
star too annoyed by your brother
Oh the critic in the shoe tree little
nice yes yes so all right now yes super
sweet now we have the actual gift gifts
all right till that's to death all right
I get to open one / yeah
hey hey hey Midtown yeah you're the
chest
it's great it's red paper no it's not it
is it says keep away from the fire
oh it sees is a Santa Claus bottle
wrapper
oh nothing the little hand on it we will
put this out there got into Santa wine
cozy we're gonna gonna put this out at
the channel awesome Christmas party hey
Tara I'm just going good now this is
before I knew I literally all of them
angry here is Johnny I didn't know
Johnny can I get open minds ones for me
if you want me to no that's - huh we
assist me uh yeah that's you oh here oh
oh oh here gyms open or is this - Zeke
that is very very very adorable thank
you that's my cuz why look at you Jim I
think Oh Hank you know let's do let's do
a kylo ren's yeah I will finish what you
started
I was deal Christmas okay that arrogant
you uh sorry um it says lol is
California right very nice oh that was
an easy job opening Nats and somebody
started hey listen to her see wow that's
so cool oh my god awesome oh my god
that's totally a fallout fallout
reference oh my gosh
okay I gotta tell it again oh thank you
so much that's so cool
you should play video games I should
play five everyone talks about fallout
it's the best
so like selection screens you'll love
how thanks Jimmy
it says to Malcolm where is this to Z
that's adorable that's my nickname that
go by for my tiger character keep on
guessing tired yes there are me well rat
just rich are well known for their
rapping yeah thank you open gifts much
this was just like especially Rhett oh
oh I see some cheetah color hey onyx no
Malcolm she knows it's not a wine cozy
but why would you look at you - Rob you
should expect nothing less for me ooh
Randy oh no I'm kind of worried ritzer's
it's fucking hard yeah they like aziza
this is why they had an empire its March
their ass ordered a rapid good this is
like an ice cream sundae sweet and it's
very suing of yeah it actually if it's
successful whoa take off the other
glasses you moron but then I can't see
we can see for you and trust you can see
how stupid you look from a mile away
Wow that's her get ahead you're saying I
look stupid no no you know
it's like is it a Sunday or is it like
cuz it's like the red and the green and
the no like I think it's supposed to be
like a Sunday kind of are like Ali or
something you know I would have totally
won this too ha ha ha ha like a
Christmas Harry Potter yeah Merry
Christmas Harry Potter somedays Maxim's
and then this one's to me it says too
much Suez oh oh crap yeah oh my god I
love this oh wait a second I wonder if
this is like some British dessert like
the main coffee puddings or the sticky
pudding or the I don't know oh my god oh
yeah Christmas motherfucker Randy Savage
oh yeah yeah together oh we're twins
can't you tell adorable adorable I think
Hitler dorks so yeah I think that's the
last gift there so the only one we have
left is for Adams a you know DS DS not
here got rest his soul oh we forgot to
tell you we will we will get that to him
as well when we do we will definitely
feel bad so uh yeah thank you so much as
it's very very cool so thank you so much
oh it's a one-size Brown desert okay so
this is this is one size bro Oh Oh looks
like a Brita and it costs two L's
and I said that's British for love to
loves so two pounds go on the euro you
put ahead so Merry Christmas to wall and
Brad do you have anything to say oh yeah
thanks for they gonna me motherfucker